from soft and smooth to coarse and rough
Anakin Skywalker's journey to become
Darth Vader has been a rocky one it's
not easy being the scariest guy in the
Galaxy now that Obi-Wan has had his
rematch this is everything you need to
know about the Four Rise and Redemption
of Darth Vader four decades before he
walked on to Princess Leia's ship as the
embodiment of the evil empire when
audiences got their first glimpse of
Darth Vader Anakin Skywalker was born in
Tatooine as a child of a slave woman
named shmee Skywalker when the Jedi
Master Qui-Gon Jin asked me about the
boy's father years later she simply told
him that there wasn't one leading
Qui-Gon to deduce that Anakin had been
conceived by the force entities known as
midichlorians though it hasn't been
conclusively stated it's heavily implied
in both the film and the comics that
Anakin's conception was caused by the
manipulations of the Sith Lord Darth
Plagueis and his Apprentice Darth
Sidious Anakin showed tremendous
intelligence and skill from a very young
age and was so Adept at mechanics and
repairs that he built the protocol Droid
C-3PO before he'd turned 10. he was also
a skilled Pod racer making him a Rarity
as human reflexes were usually too slow
to allow them to survive in the sport
which drew the attention of a pair of
Jedi Knights after learning about
Anakin's curious parentage and testing
his midichlorian pounds Qui-Gon became
convinced of Anakin's potential as a
Jedi with qui-gon's encouragement Anakin
won his freedom in a pod race and a
company Qui-Gon and Obi-Wan to Coruscant
sadly having to leave his mother behind
Qui-Gon took Anakin before the Jedi High
Council convinced that the boy could be
the chosen one who would bring balance
to the force Masters Yoda and Mace Windu
were worry of Anakin's age and his
fearful demeanor but Qui-Gon pleaded for
the opportunity to train him anyway in
the Battle of Naboo Anakin piloted a
Starfighter against the Trade Federation
proving that his Jedi reflexes and
skillers of Pilots extended Beyond Pod
racing after the battle was over he
discovered that Qui-Gon had been killed
at the hands of Darth Maul and Obi-Wan
made a Val to train Anakin himself in
keeping with his lost Master's Wishes
the High Council consented and Anakin
became a Jedi Padawan Anakin spent the
next decade training as Obi-Wan's
apprentice and proved himself as an
immensely skilled Jedi who also had a
tendency towards recklessness as a young
man he reconnected with then Senator
Padme amadala on coruscantes when he and
Obi-Wan were tasked with guarding her
life after an assassination attempt we
will find out who's trying to kill you
Padme
I promise you we will not exceed our
mandate my young Padawan learner while
Obi-Wan sought to track down the people
behind the attempt on padme's life
Anakin stayed behind as her personal
bodyguard and escorted her back to Naboo
the senator and the Jedi soon fell in
love but Anakin's dark attendance is
intruded as he became tormented by
visions of his mother with Padme at his
side Anakin traveled to Tatooine where
he learned that a now married and freed
Shmi Skywalker have been abducted by
Tuscan Raiders Anakin Tracked Down The
Tuscan tribe and his mother who died in
his arms after seeing him one last time
in a rage a Skywalker slaughtered the
entire tribe and valdapad may that he
would become powerful enough to prevent
the people he loved from dying beginning
his descent into darkness after the
Tuscan Raider incident Anakin and Padme
left Tatooine to rescue Obi-Wan he'd
been taken prisoner by separatists and
fortunately they like Obi-Wan was soon
captured by separatist leader Seth Lord
and former Dracula Count Dooku and
sentenced to death in a gladiatorial
Arena as they tried to fight their way
out alongside the Jedi reinforcements
arrived in the form of a clone army that
had been discovered by Obi-Wan under the
leadership of yodu and Mace Windu they
defeated the separatists in what would
become the first battle of the Clone
Wars with the battle still raging Anakin
and Obi-Wan engaged Dooku in a
lightsaber duel but Anakin's
recklessness got the better of him when
he tried to fight Dooku alone the sets
defeated Anakin cutting off Anakin's
right arm before being defeated by Yoda
in the days that followed Anakin and
Padme were married in secret with the
Droid C-3PO and R2D2 serving as
Witnesses because the Jedi Order forbade
such romantic attachments as the Clone
Wars gained intensity Anakin was
promoted to Jedi Knight and became a key
general for the Republic his abilities
and confidence grew but so did his
recklessness and by extension his fear
of losing those he loved in an effort to
help Yoda suggested Anna King could
learn how to let go of people by taking
on an apprentice of his own who would
one day Ascend Beyond his training he
was paired with a young Padawan named
Ahsoka Tano and while the two initially
had friction due to ahsoka's feisty
nature they ultimately became friends
Master if you've taught me one thing is
that nothing is easy when you're around
Ahsoka Rose in prominent alongside her
master as the wars went on until she was
framed and arrested for a bombing at the
Jedi Temple that was actually carried
out by one of her friends Ahsoka was
expelled from the Jedi Order but Anakin
and Padme believe in her innocence and
were ultimately able to gain evidence
that led to her acquittal at trial
though she was offered we admission to
the ranks of the Jedi Ahsoka was
disillusioned after her trial and she
chose to leave the Jedi behind
witnessing the treatment of his former
Apprentice only served to further for
straight Anakin who was beginning to
lose faith in the Jedi High Council by
the end of the Clone Wars Anakin's
growing abilities and his purported
status as the chosen one caught the
attention of the Sith Lord Darth Sidious
Sidious was manipulating the entire war
from behind the scenes via his dull
roles as a Sith and a sheath Palpatine
yes that's his first name the chancellor
of the Republic Palpatine finally made
his move on Skywalker in the waning days
of the war urging him to kill Dooku In
Cold Blood in the midst of space above
Coruscant and a king complied
decapitating Dooku and Palpatine
continued grooming Anakin as agent by
appointing him as his Emissary to the
Jedi Council the council submitted to
the Chancellor's wishes but they refused
to Grant Anakin the rank of Master
further inflaming his frustrations
though Obi-Wan continued to Champion him
I have trained you since you were a
small boy I have taught you everything I
know
and you have become a far greater Jedi
than I could ever hope to be
unfortunately the denial of Anakin's
Knighthood coupled with his frequent
visions of Padme who was then pregnant
dying in despair LED Palpatine to
finally reveal himself to Anakin
convincing him that he could stop the
death of his loved ones by using the
dark side of the force conflicted Anakin
first revealed that Palpatine was a Sith
Lord and then helped Palpatine kill Mace
Windu in the hopes of learning how to
save Padme though distressed by his
betrayal of the Jedi Anakin submitted
himself to his new master who in turn
dubbed him Darth Vader Palpatine
dispatched Vader to the Jedi Temple as
part of his great Jedi Purge where Vader
brutally slaughtered any Force user in
his path including the children Vader
then journeyed to the fiery Planet
Mustafa with Obi-Wan and padmei Having
learned of his portrayal following to
stop him enraged by the idea that his
old master and his wife are working
together to betray him he used to force
to choke Padme into unconsciousness that
engaged Obi-Wan in the door ultimately
Obi-Wan gained The High Ground in the
fight severed both of Vader's legs and
left him near a lava dead to die
Palpatine saved his Apprentice then
outfitted him in a life preserving suit
of armor transforming him into the half
machine Vader we all know and love
Palpatine also told Vader that he'd
accidentally killed Padme and their
unborn child back on Mustafa in truth
badmayer died of a broken heart but not
before secretly giving birth to Anakin's
twin children Luke and Leia who were
hidden away from him as they grew up
Vader then took his place at Palpatine's
side as the Republic became the Galactic
Empire although he's still hard but a
desire to bring Padme back at all costs
immediately after receiving his new
robotic body armor Darth Vader was
tasked by Palpatine with his first
lesson as a Sith building a new
lightsaber but this wasn't as easy as
Vader had hoped as it turned out he was
to retrieve the lightsaber of a Jedi and
corrupt its kyver Crystal turning it to
blood red eventually Vader found master
in filler who had escaped order 66's
Jedi Purge due to his vow to remove
himself from society as Penance after
intense battle Vader killed the Jedi
Master stole his lightsaber and
destroyed ambala City in the process
though the battle nearly destroyed his
new armor after bending the kyber
crystal to his will Vader presented his
new red lightsaber to his master who was
pleased with the results using his
engineering skills Vader reconstructed
and enhanced his own armor to further
insulate himself from any potential
weakness after this Vader was introduced
to the Grand Inquisitor and his
inquisitors former Jedi tasked by the
Empire with hunting down and destroying
any trace of the Jedi Order Palpatine
then assigned their training to Lord
Vader who began using his own pain to
fuel their hatred as they scoured the
Galaxy in Search of Lost Jedi Vader's
power only grew and he strayed further
and further from his life as Anakin
Skywalker two decades past that the
Empire continued to rise and Vader
continued his efforts to eradicate the
remaining Jedi he also had to deal with
Palpatine schemes to encourage his
competitive nature by drafting other
Warriors who could serve as fader's
replacement at the emperor's side it was
during this era that Palpatine gifted
Vader a mask belonging to Momen an
ancient Sith Lord and artist whose
Spirit still possessed the mask Vader
used a Gateway opened by moment to
search for padme's spirit and bring her
back but instead he found Darkness as
her form disintegrated before his eyes
Vader came out of the experience
convinced that both Padme and Anakin
Skywalker were dead and that his past no
longer mattered as dark and heartless as
ever Darth Vader became even more
enraged in his Pursuits of former Jedi
and Empire conquests alike however
Vader's Vision showed him one other
thing a Beacon of Hope in the form of an
unidentified young man who had soon meet
presence have not felt since
nearly 10 years after their last
encounter Darth Vader got wind of the
location of his former Jedi Master
Obi-Wan Kenobi now going by Ben under
intelligence from the third sister an
Inquisitor and former Jedi youngling
named Riva Vader and his inquisitors
finally found Kenobi on the planet of
mapuzo Vader tormented the small mining
Colony killing everyone in his path
until the Jedi revealed himself once he
did their rematch immediately commenced
this still wasn't as elegant as their
previous battle as Kenobi was a bit out
of practice and didn't put up much of a
fight in retaliation Vader burned his
former master in the same way that he
himself had been burned on Mustafar
nearly a decade earlier still the
rebellion helped Kenobi escape and Vader
pursued in the chaos Vader was betrayed
by the third sister thirsty for Revenge
after Anakin Skywalker's massacre at the
Jedi Temple during Order 66 Vader
quickly overpowered the former youngling
and left her to die so that he might
continue after after Kenobi eventually
Darth Vader caught up with the Jedi and
they dawled once more this time both
have full power although Vader first
overpowered Kenobi finally gaining The
High Ground the Jedi found new strength
to defeat the Sith Lord here Vader
acknowledged that Obi-Wan didn't kill
Anakin he did it himself as Kenobi left
believing Anakin was truly dead Vader
was called back by the emperor forced to
abandon his revenge a few years later
Vader was tasked with finding a group of
rebels on a ship called ghost after a
fierce battle against a Jedi Kanan jarus
and his Apprentice Ezra Bridger on the
planet's lothal Lord Vader failed to
capture this group The Ghost crew would
go on to work with Vader's former
Apprentice Ahsoka Tano and the Rebellion
while Vader continued to send
inquisitors after them and occasionally
pursue them himself on the ancient Sith
Homeworld malachor Ezra and Kanan
eventually found the Sith Temple where
they encountered Vader once again as the
Sith Lord fought the young Jedi Master
and his Apprentice Ahsoka arrived to
help it's here that she finally learned
the Dark Truth Anakin Skywalker didn't
die at the end of the Clone Wars he
became Darth Vader Vader attempted to
convert Ahsoka believing that the
emperor would forgive her treason if she
gave up other Jedi and the rebels but
Ahsoka refused
[Music]
die
as the Seth Temple collapsed around them
Vader and Ahsoka continued to duel until
Ahsoka miraculously escaped leaving
Vader defeated and alone once more
Imperial scientists and Engineers
including Galen erso and Orson krennic
worked hard to build a super weapon
capable of destroying entire planets the
Death Star but urso was secretly a rebel
sympathizer who leaked the death star's
weakness to his daughter Jin and a group
of rebels after testing the Death Star
and the moon of Jeddah krennic was sent
to Darth Vader's fortress on Mustafa
seem unsettled Vader reminded krennic
that the Death Star was not officially
supposed to exist and that he should be
careful the rebel soon attacks the
planet scarif where the plans for the
Death Star were being kept forcing the
Empire to act swiftly the Empire used a
death star to destroy the Rebels on the
ground along with krennic but the plans
were transmitted to a nearby Rebel Ship
which Vader had secretly invaded the
Death Star plans escaped on the Tanta V4
which unbeknownst to Vader also houses
own long-lost daughter Leia the
rebellion's unexpected Advantage Force
Vader to pursue the rebels he managed to
capture Princess Leia who sent a message
to Obi-Wan Kenobi on satawine before her
capture Grandma Tarkin the death star's
Commander had Vader torture layer who he
did not know was his daughter and even
used the space station to destroy her
adoptive Homeworld of old Iran as they
tried to gain the location of the Rebel
alliance's secret base stubborn like her
biological father Leia refused to give
up her friend ends it wouldn't be long
before allies came to rescue Leia which
meant Vader had an unexpected encounter
with an old friend when this small group
which included Vader's long-lostson Luke
Skywalker who he was also unaware of and
his former Jedi Master Obi-Wan Ben
Kenobi infiltrated the Death Star to
rescue Leia Vader and Kenobi fought for
the final time Vader killed his old
teacher but the rescue was successful
and the rebels were clear to use the
Death Star plans unfortunately in all
the commotion Tarkin discovered the
rebel base on Yavin IV after secretly
tracking the Millennium Falcon there in
an epic space battle Vader nearly killed
Luke thus the young Skywalker was saved
at the last moment by Han Solo and
Vader's Starfighter was sent hurtling
into space Guided by the ghost of Ben
Kenobi Luke blew up the Death Star
the destruction of the Death Star was a
major victory for the rebellion and a
huge blow to the Empire this set Vader
on a journey of self-discovery after the
attack Luke Skywalker Leia Organa and
Han Solo went on a mission to blow up an
imperial facility when they encountered
Vader once more Luke attempted to do the
Sith Lord and in the process Vader
recognized Luke's lightsaber as his
former weapon of choice the same one it
lost to Obi-Wan Kenobi on Mustafar 20
years earlier after learning that the
emperor hoped to replace him Vader put
his own team together including bounty
hunters Boba Fett and black chrysanthen
and the archaeologist Dr Aphra to learn
more about the boy who blew up the Death
Star fair to learn that the boy who dual
Darth Vader was named Skywalker at that
moment Vader realized that he'd been
deceived in keeping with the Sith rule
of two in which apprentices kill their
masters to ascend to master Hood Vader
plans to convert his son to the dark
side kill the emperor and rule the
galaxy after learning the truth about
his son Darth Vader continued to search
for Luke to join forces with him in
order to usurp the emperor Dr Afra
learned Luke's location on the world of
ragus Vaz which was also home to a
long-lost Jedi Temple and eventually
shared the info with the Sith Lord who
swiftly went to retrieve his prize
though he destroyed nearly two whole
Rebel squadrons Vader was quickly
defeated after Luke sacrificed himself
by ramming his X-Wing directly into
Vader's TIE fighter sending both father
and son hurtling to the planet below
there Vader fended off Rebel troops
including a brief reunion with Leia
while Aphra attempted to abduct Luke
unfortunately for the dark lord Luke's
friends Han Solo Chewbacca r2ditu and
C-3PO all fought back saving him and
kidnapping Aphra for information on the
Empire although he had failed to attain
his son Vader wouldn't quit they would
have to put his plan on pause while the
emperor sends him on various diplomatic
missions to maintain order throughout
the Empire after the death star's
destruction eventually Vader caughts up
with Afra and seemingly killed her by
releasing her into open space let's hope
that the Dark Lord knows she survived
with the help of her loyal allies it
wouldn't be much longer before Vader
tracked Luke and by extension the rebels
down to their hidden base on the icy
Planet Hearth the Empire invaded the
planet while the rebels evacuated and
Luke once again escaped Vader's clutches
but just barely shortly after this
failure Palpatine revealed his knowledge
of Luke to Vader Anza II began working
to bring the younger Skywalker over to
the dark side to achieve this Vader
launched the campaign to find Luke's
friends on board the Millennium Falcon
at all costs with the help of bounty
hunter Boba Fett he eventually captured
Han and Leia on bespin and used them as
baits to lure Luke who had been training
to become a Jedi Knight with an exiled
Yoda and the ghost of Ben Kenobi on the
swamp Planet Dagobah the plan words and
Luke arrived on bespin to battle Vader
and save his friends Vader defeated the
young Jedi in a lightsaber door severing
Luke's right hand in the process only to
reveal to Luke that he was his true
father Vader pleaded with Luke hoping
that he would join him in overthrowing
the emperor but Luke refused instead the
young Skywalker chose to fall to his
death fortunately he dropped through the
bowels of a bespin Mining facility where
he was rescued by Leia in the Millennium
Falcon leaving Darth Vader alone once
more after Luke's rejection and the
visit to his childhood home of Tatooine
Darth Vader began an investigation into
the death of his wife Padme and the
birth of his son during this
investigation he met a woman who looked
almost exactly like the former queen of
Naboo padme's former handmaiden Sabe
they worked together for a while
searching the Boo for more evidence of
who killed Padme that is until Vader
himself eventually confessed to the
crime Sabe and her team fought Vader but
they were no match for his raw power
upon entering padme's tomb and scanning
her corpse Vader discovered a medical
implants that led him to the Polish
Master asteroid field which held the
facility where Padme gave birth to Luke
and Leia Vader scanned the records and
found a final recording of Padme
speaking with his former Master Obi-Wan
reminding him that there was still good
in Anakin disappointed by his Apprentice
this morning the emperor tortured and
left Vader for dead on Mustafa
instructing him to rebuild himself he
did and was eventually led to the Sith
world of exagol but he was given a
glimpse of The Emperor's true power as
well as a Sith clothing programs it
implemented which would continue long
after the Empire after initially hoping
to regain some agency Darth Vader once
again surrendered to his master and
Emperor Palpatine took his Apprentice
back with open arms after seeing the
emperor's true power on hexagonal Darth
Vader abandoned his dreams of Luke
becoming his Apprentice believing
Palpatine was too powerful to overcome
instead Vader decided to kill his son
and continue to pursue him as he
enforced the Empire's will Across the
Universe after the Frozen and carbonized
Han Solo was stolen from the Empire
Vader sought to retrieve him believing
that Luke would eventually return for
his friend arriving at an auction for
solo Vader learned that Crimson Dawn a
criminal organization once run by Darth
Maul now run by Solo's Old Flame Kira
was selling the rebel Smuggler upon
attaining solo Vader encountered his son
once more in an aerial battle one that
ended with Vader's TIE fighter crashing
once again here Luke even considered
killing his father ending the threat of
Darth Vader for good but he decided
against it still reeling from their
previous encounter Vader then continued
to Faithfully serve the Empire by
hunting down and destroying the Agents
of crimson Dawn on his mission to end
Crimson Dawn he once again encountered
Sabe who led him to a colony of former
Tatooine slaves on the world of gabrador
3. but only after revealing that she
knew the truth about Anakin Skywalker on
that planet Vader met two of his
childhood friends from Tatooine kitster
and Wald before the plan's completion of
the second death star Palpatine planned
to use their new super weapon as bait to
ensnare and defeat the Rebellion all
while using it to lure Luke Skywalker to
the battle station Luke re-emerged on
Endor where he surrendered to Vader Luke
was fully determined to redeem his
father just as Vader was once again
determined to convert his son Vader
brought loot before the Emperor who
attempted to provoke anger in him by
revealing his plan to trap the rebels
after all anger leads to the dark side
this sparked a Final Duel between Darth
Vader and his son and during the fight
Vader sensed in his son's mind that he
had a sister Vader's second child using
this knowledge Vader Drew Luke's anger
out and Luke defeated Vader with Force
but seconds before killing his father
Luke realized he was becoming just like
Vader so he tossed his weapon aside
refusing to join the Dark Side and
raised Palpatine retaliated with forced
lightning watching his son die in agony
Vader reclaimed the good part of himself
that Padme once spoke of and threw his
master down the core shaft of the Death
Star seemingly killing him Gravely
injured by Palpatine Darth Vader didn't
have much longer to live birth with his
dying breath Anakin Skywalker returned
to the light assuring his son that he
was right all along the rebels victory
at a second death star marked the
beginning of the end for the Galactic
Empire Vader's Legacy is a dark side
Legend lived on however and took a route
again in the form of his grandson Leia
and Hans kid Ben solo Ben caught the eye
of snoke a powerful Dark Side user and
Scholar who sensed the dark side
potential in the Skywalker bloodline and
he sought to cultivate it within Ben he
succeeded and Ben solo rose up against
his uncle Jedi Master Luke Skywalker
ending Luke's attempt to rebuild the
Jedi Order when he finally turned to the
dark side Ben solo changed his name to
kylo Ren and vowed to finish Vader's
mission to eradicate the Jedi he even
acquired Vader's old helmet which had
been partially burned in his funeral
pyre kylo Ren's quest to further his
grandfather's Legacy had dire
consequences spurred on by snoke he
helped the Empire like first order
developer Death Star ex superweapon
known as Starkiller base although it was
destroyed by a band of rebels who dubbed
themselves to resistance that Victory
came with horrific loss of life
including the death of Han Solo murdered
by kylo himself kylo then pursued the
resistance across the Galaxy before a
final showdown with his old Master Luke
Skywalker or at least a force field
Apparition he believed to be luke their
battle was just a ruse meant to give the
first order's enemies time to flee and
although kylo was unable to defeat Luke
in person the effort it took to project
his presence ultimately ended
Skywalker's presence on the physical
plane kylo's Campaign Of Terror finally
ended on hexagall where he tracked a
cloned Palpatine and faced off against
him alongside the budding Jedi known as
Rey who in a last minute twist turns out
to be the old Emperor's secret
granddaughter realizing too late that
had been LED horribly astray kylo helped
Rey defeat Palpatine sacrificing himself
in the process and adding one final
parallel to Vader's portion of the
Skywalker Saga check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
Looper videos about Star Wars are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
foreign
[Music]